what's the most common mistake a new
screenwriter makes well one thing is is
to think that there's just one draft and
that it's going to flow out of them and
that there's nothing to learn as opposed
to that sense of a process but there is
a very fine balance between one's art
and one's craft the place that the flow
happens the place where you feel your
voice is being coming out and the
shaping of the voice the shaping of what
that artistic form is and it one has to
be careful about that balance because
you learn a lot about craft but it is
this is an art form it's not a
paint-by-numbers it's not saying oh my
first turning point is on page 27
instead of 32 oh my is say well let's
look more carefully because maybe you're
exactly in the right place for that and
so there can be when people take
seminars or read books they can get into
the paint by numbers or on the other
hand you can have people who are you
know so into their art that they don't
want to learn and I say you can't use it
if you don't know it
so knowledge doesn't hurt you it just
has to be put in its right place and
then there's the danger of thinking that
that first screenplay is going to be the
million dollar idea yes this weekend is
this it this is a work through and I
know that when I write my non-fiction
books I presume every chapter will be
rewritten at least 5 a minimum but
generally about 10 times that'll be gone
over and over I ask an Emmy
award-winning screenwriter once I said
how many times you rewrite she said well
this morning I rewrote the scene 22
times and my guess is she probably was
whether 22 is because she was a comedy
writer but my guess is it wasn't four
times and going over and over and saying
this word resin
it's better or not having this line of
dialogue but having an image instead or
having a reaction oh yeah that is better
and so you you massage I mean you you
really are reworking and reworking and
reworking and sometimes people think
we'll the great writers I guess it just
flows you say no the great writers are
probably rewriting more than the merely
good writers and get used to the rewrite
process and get used to feedback and get
used to honing and tweaking and
recognize that's the process
you